so i asked the community to describe the
sequel trilogy in
one word but before i give my thoughts
here is a quick little montage of what
people think
[Music]
so
[Music]
anakin is describing a sequel trilogy
here is sand
that's a that's a little harsh anyway
let's continue
discombobulate i mean yeah i guess you
could say the secret trilogy was kind of
confusing or it could have confused you
um but i think a better way to describe
it was it it wasn't cohesive
i guess you could say they kind of just
made one passed it off to someone else
and they you know you they tried to
continue it or a clash of visions i
guess you could say
like one director had one vision the
other director had a different vision a
lot of stuff was changing all the time
like uh rey at one point was a nobody
and then she was a palpatine
but anyway let's continue disappointing
disappointed
disappointed yeah i think that's a fair
way to describe the sequel trilogy in
one word because you know
people haven't seen a star wars movie
for such a long time so people's
expectations were through the roof
and what people got is i think not what
people expected
for example people really wanted luke
skywalker to be like the jedi badass the
grand master from legends
and people were not ready for the
expectations to be subverted when saying
that and
there's a whole other like side of the
story where people love the sequels or
they love what they did to luke or other
characters um
it's very controversial personally
there's actually some themes from the
last jedi that i love
such as the whole failure aspect of luke
and yoda teaching him that
um lesson i thought that was really well
done i think the people
chosen to make the sequels were the
incorrect people they played it too safe
episode eight got a lot of backlash
episode nine try to fix
stuff and you know that's just not how
you write a story you don't try to fix
things that people don't like or
cater towards people to try you know
satisfy it just doesn't work
i find lack of creativity disturbing
that isn't one word but
that is a good point well i guess you
could say uncreative because the secret
trilogies were yeah a little uncreative
they didn't really bring anything new
you know the first order was kind of a
rehash of the
empire nothing really new nothing really
different i know that it must be one
word but paraphrase in general grievous
this will not
make a fine addition to my collection
yeah fair enough
fair enough i mean they're just movies
if you only like episodes one to six
just watch episodes one to six if people
like the sequels then they can watch
episodes seven to nine you know you
don't have to like a movie
and you don't have to dislike a movie um
i think it they're very subjective
so if you don't like them just don't
watch them and make up your own head
cannon no problem
anyway guys we're going to wrap up this
video um also if you didn't comment on
the community posts
um please tell me in the comment section
below how you would describe the sequel
trilogy
in one word and also guys tell me do you
want to see more type of videos like
this
because you know it's it's quite
different to what i usually do i'm just
experimenting a little bit so if you
don't like it no problem
if you do let me know and i'll leave a
[Music]
like
[Music]
monkey